bonjour eric diard merci d'être en
direct avec nous alors la cité phocéenne
se rebelle contre les nouvelles
restrictions beaucoup de personnes
devant le tribunal de commerce marseille
est ce que vous partagez cette colère
des patrons de bars restaurants qui ont
pour obligation de fermer leur
établissement pendant quinze jours
oui je parte cette colère parce que
c'est une décision qui n'a pas été
concerté
elle a été brutal nous étions pas
avertit même l' agence régionale de
santé vient de reconnaître
qu'actuellement
a marseille il y a eu une stabilisation
puis une baisse je donne des résultats
nous sommes nous étions à 8,7 pour cent
de positivité nous sommes passés à 7%
dans les bouches du rhône et pour
marseille on est passé de 10,1 10,10 à
10,1 pour cent alors c'est encore très
élevé c'est le même chiffre qu'au paris
mais ont souhaité que le ministre dise
voilà les chiffres sont telles qu elles
il ya une baisse mais si dans une
semaine ça ne baisse pas plus nous
prendrons des mesures non nous avons mis
été nous avons tous été mis devant le
fait accompli alors ce bras de fer entre
la ville et et l'autorité risque de
prendre une tournure judiciaire puisque
renaud muselier le président de la
région paca annoncé qu'il déposerait un
référé liberté pour tenter de faire
plier l'état c'est possible selon où
selon vous c'est possible juste cela
concerne l'ensemble de la métropole est
marseille ça veut dire pas seulement
marseille pas seulement x mais en tout
92 communes et des communes de 5000
habitants qui est donc parfois aucun cas
dans leur commune pour voir le
restaurant leurs bars fermés ou leur
salle de sport donc c'est une profonde
injustice alors il ya une discussion
parce que ya pas de marge de manoeuvre
c'est une décision brutale qu'on veut
dire mais il ya une décision parce que
le préfet peut être peut voir un petit
peu le périmètre de cette décision de
fermeture et ya intégré qu'une partie
des villes de la métropole alors le
premier confinement était vraiment un
coup dur pour tous les
les professionnels que ce soit justement
les bars et restaurants y lire soir jean
castex qui assume
justement ces mesures a promis une
indemnisation pour les établissements
concernés
qu'en pensez vous et c'est toujours
pareil à carotte et le bâton
donc quand vous a mis un coup de bâton
et puis maintenant on vous sort une
carotte
ce qu'on souhaitait nous les élus c'est
qu' on puisse en parler auparavant qu'on
puisse discuter responsabilité qui
réunissent les collectivités les
parlementaires les services de l'état
pour dire voilà les l'échéance si on
n'arrive pas meilleur résultat nous en
arriverons à fermer les bars des
restaurants ou les salles de sport ça
n'a pas été le cas
je vais vous dire que la veille j'étais
à paris je n'ai entendu rien c'est le
président de région de ce muselier qui a
seulement été au courant une demi heure
avant l'annoncé du ministre de la santé
en fait vous reprocher le fait de ne pas
avoir été concerté pas la mesure en
elle-même vous auriez mais justement
être voilà qu'il y ait eu une discussion
avant que le gouvernement annonce cette
fermeture définitive des débats récents
mais promis avant une discussion et
deuxièmement c'est profondément injuste
il s'appuie sur des chiffres de la
semaine dernière et on le constate
marseille a eu un une hausse et un piqué
puis maintenant arrive sur un plateau et
on entame d'une baisse donc j'aurais
souhaité voir le ministre en disant nous
sommes dans une phase de baisse
je souhaite que la baisse arrive à tel
point si elle n'arrive pas assez tel
point je pendrai telles mesures
drastiques voilà ce qu'il fallait faire
au lieu 2 de nous mettre devant le fait
accompli pour vous le gouvernement vous
ne gère pas très bien c'est cette crise
sanitaire
mais disons vous entendez la république
dira oui on va décentraliser on va
écouter les acteurs locaux etc
et là vous avez l'exemple d'une décision
technocratique qui viennent d'un
ministère et qui s'impose à tous merci
beaucoup
eric diard d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
député et l'ère des bouches du rhône